we're getting an inside look at a
controversial approach to the nation's
drug epidemic which has taken more than
100 000 lives in the past year overdose
prevention centers like this give
addicts space to use illegal drugs more
safely with trained staff standing by to
help if they overdose supervised drug
sites have been in use for decades
overseas but until recently there were
none in this country senior medical
correspondent dr tara narula got an
inside look at one of the first two in
the u.s right here in new york city
at this east harlem overdose prevention
center sam rivera is executive director
and guardian angel to many struggling
with addiction when they use in the
street they're hiding in an alley alone
they're hiding in the bathroom alone if
they overdose no one's there they bother
bobby you get to respond immediately and
those are key moments because
those are moments where some people will
say this is it you're the safety net
definitely the safety net in the moment
while they're in their use
that safety net is saving lives on
average more than 2 000 people in new
york city die from drug overdoses each
year in just the first five months of
operation the two centers intervened 283
times without a single death
rivera knows all too well how illegal
drugs turn lives upside down i created
some pain in my own community and i paid
for it when rivera was in his 20s he
spent five years behind bars on
drug-related charges in prison he worked
with hiv-positive inmates that
experience changed his life and led him
to help other marginalized people using
compassion and the concept of harm
reduction the drug use
exists
what we want to do is reduce the harm
associated with the drug use clean
needles and other supplies reduce the
risk of infection mirrored booths allow
staff to watch for drug reactions
they're not going to like push the
actual like drug into you but they're
going to
guide you after staying clean for two
years christina peterson started using
heroin again during the pandemic they
strive to you know to i guess kind of
teach people about harm reduction rather
than complete abstinence that's not
really the reality for a lot of people
these are the overdose carts program
director kalyn c says quicker response
times allow them the option to use less
invasive life-saving measures like nasal
naloxone we're able to resolve 85
percent of the overdoses with just
oxygen alone and if we need to we're
just doing micro doses of the injectable
naloxone for those hundred thousand plus
overdoses america saw last year if
someone was there when it happened
those people wouldn't have died taxpayer
dollars cover wellness services medical
care and connections to rehab but since
the drugs brought in are illegal only
private donations fund the drug
supervision area for people who say
you're just allowing people to come in
and use you're not getting them help we
believe that abstinence and harm
reduction are partners in this fight
against overdose you cannot recover you
cannot live your life you cannot do the
things you want for yourself if you
don't survive an overdose
despite resistance from community groups
the program is allowed to operate
without raids or arrests new york city
mayor eric adams tells cbs news he
supports the centers and the department
of justice told us it's evaluating
supervised consumption sites as part of
an overall approach to harm reduction
and public safety
[Music]
since i was 16. omar torres says the
staff here gives him something he
doesn't usually receive respect how
often have you been here every day every
day no longer this is open because
they're not opening the weekends and i
wish it was yeah why why do you wish it
was because on the weekends we don't
know where to go so we gotta be in the
hallways or on the streets and people
get mad at us wanna fight us throw
things at us
call us names you know and we're not
animals we're actually good people we
just addiction
sam rivera wants this facility to serve
as a blueprint for other harm reduction
centers across the country to offer more
people the same second chance he got and
to people who say you're bringing drugs
into our community we don't want these
centers in our neighborhood we're in the
neighborhoods we're in because drugs are
already here we're not coming in with
them we're keeping humans alive so they
get an opportunity and i can introduce
you to hundreds and thousands
who because of these programs are still
here and are productive members of
society you're taking something out of
the darkness and bringing it into the
light yes lots of light
and you know people call it radical and
i call it righteous
san francisco and other cities are
considering this model which not only
saves lives but money spent on emergency
services opponents in the community
acknowledge there has been a reduction
in drug paraphernalia litter but they
remain opponents right because people
think it's encouraging drug use correct
and i think i know i'm struggling a
little bit with it it's a hard concept
to understand but harm reduction and
these principles have been used around
the world for 30 years and the idea is
they're going to use it anyway i'm going
to use it so now you're watching them
you're preventing that overdose you're
allowing them the opportunity to try to
get to rehab and many times it takes
more than one time an attempt to rehab
to get clean
space but how successful is this program
in terms of getting addicts clean right
so there the center said they don't have
the numbers on that yet and that is
definitely obviously one of the goals
but it's really to treat the whole
person to give them back their
self-worth they have a clinic there they
have social support they have wellness
services and as sam said to me you know
this is about providing dignity to a
population that is seen as disposable
right right and they're not chances in a
second
i like it radical some people call it
radical he calls it righteous yeah
exactly
like that the tough love take it outside
approach has not been working for
decades dr terenola thank you so much
all right and you can hear more of
tara's conversation with sam rivera on
today's cbs morning's podcast we'll be
right back